WESTON HUTCHINS: Hello?
Hey, everyone.
I was really hoping
we were going
to run into Justin
Bieber soundtrack.
They had some great
music playing.
I was hoping we were going
to break through a wall
or something, but you know.
MANDY WAITE: Yeah,
keep the music playing.
I was enjoying that.
WESTON HUTCHINS:
Welcome, everyone.
We have the dubious 1:00 PM
after lunch hour session.
We hope that you're
going to be as
excited for this
presentation as we are.
The title of this is, "Making
Your Cloud Service Google
Fast."
Some quick intros.
My name is Weston Hutchins.
I am a product manager on the
Google Cloud Platform Team.
MANDY WAITE: My
name is Mandy Waite.
I'm a developer advocate for
the Google Cloud platform.
WESTON HUTCHINS: She's my
Dev rock star for today.
And today's talk, it's really
hard to talk about a topic
as deep as performance
in 30 minutes,
so Mandy and I have cherry
picked a few tips and tricks.
We're going to show you guys
some demos on top of Google
Cloud Platform and how
we can make your app as
fast as possible leveraging
the infrastructure we
use at Google.
So we've broken down
this into four topics.
The first is I'm
going to tell you
a little bit about
why fast matters.
Then Mandy's going to take over
and tell you how we think about
fast inside Google, how we
leverage the infrastructure
to build our world
class apps today.
Then the meat of
the discussion is
going to be around two topics.
One of them is measuring
fast, and how you
should think about
correctly measuring
the performance of
your application.
And then Mandy is going to
take over and tell you guys how
to scale out and scale fast so
you guys can be the next secret
app that has 1,000x growth in
your first month of use once
you reach the front
page of Hacker News.
So why fast matters.
You might be thinking,
duh, of course it matters,
but I always like to throw
out some fun facts just
to talk a little bit about
what the impact of performance
can have on your users.
There was a study done a little
while ago that Google actually
went out and intentionally
induced a server side lag delay
for every result that was coming
into the Google search page.
And they wanted to
measure the behavior
over a period of three weeks of
how often users were searching
with various amounts
of lag built in.
And what they found
was pretty interesting.
If you just increase the amount
of lag by 400 milliseconds,
it would reduce the amount
of searches by 0.6%.
And when you're talking
at Google scale,
that's actually a huge number.
It ended up being about
eight billion searches a day
at the time this study was run.
Even more so, this
study also figured out
that users are impatient,
and you guys probably
don't need me to
remind you about that.
But they found that
one in every four users
will abandon a web
page if it takes
more than four seconds to load.
And given the competitive
nature of performance nowadays,
I can only imagine
that this number
is likely to decrease over time.
Mobile apps are also
important as well.
It's not just websites that we
have to start thinking about.
There was a study that was
released just this last week
by App Dynamics, which is a
leading performance monitoring
solution out there.
What they found when they
surveyed a bunch of users
was that performance was the
number one top frustration when
using mobile apps and websites.
86% of users deleted
or uninstalled
at least one mobile
app because of problems
with application performance.
Now, there is a
silver lining there.
They also found
out that when users
are happy with your
performance, they're
going to spend more money.
30% of users said they
would spend more money
with an application
that had greater
performance over
its competitors.
So there is real incentive
here for you guys
to spend the money,
spend the time
speeding up your application
and making it fast
for your end users.
And with that, I'm going
to hand it over to Mandy,
who's going to talk about
building a culture of fast
at Google.
MANDY WAITE: Thank you, Wes.
So fast is at the core
of pretty much everything
that we do at Google.
Well, nearly everything.
And users of our
products and services
are used to experiencing a
consistently fast performance
from all of our
products and services.
You can offer that same
experience to your users
by using Google Cloud
Platform because Google Cloud
Platform runs on the very same
infrastructure as services
such as Gmail, Google
search, YouTube,
and all of our other
products and services.
So let's talk about some of the
philosophies behind the fast
at Google.
In order to meet the
traffic demand of modern day
applications, you need
the ability to scale fast.
And scale fast is
something that we're
going to talk about
in the last section,
as Wes has already mentioned.
And App Engine, our platform
as a service offering,
which we'll also
talk about shortly,
that epitomizes the notion and
the principle of scale fast.
So we have an example
of that coming up soon.
The ability to
measure fast allows
you to gain insight
and understanding
of the very complex nature of
modern day applications running
in the cloud.
And Wes is going to
talk to you very shortly
about some specific
examples around latency,
and also introduce
you to some tools
that we're going to be
making available to users
of the Google Cloud Platform.
Then there's the ability
to innovate fast.
This has really been
core to our ability
to actually keep
ahead of the game when
it comes to handling, as you can
pretty much imagine, handling
the massive amounts
of traffic demand
that we have on all of
our products and services,
and not just on the products
and services themselves,
but also on the
infrastructure that runs them.
So we've innovated rapidly
over the last 15 years,
and this is a timeline of some
of the things we've introduced,
white papers and such.
BigTable is our massively
scalable, no SWL data store,
and many of our services
use BigTable directly.
And in fact, App Engine itself
was built around BigTable.
It was actually
built around BigTable
to use it specifically.
So users of App Engine had
direct access to BigTable
as the App Engine data store.
That data store
has now been made
available to users
of the cloud platform
directly, from anywhere,
any user from anywhere
from any application, as
the Google Cloud Data Store.
Then there's Dremel.
Dremel is an analysis
tool that allows
you to run interactive queries
across massive data sets.
We're talking about terabytes
here, billions and billions
of rows of data.
And to get results back in
seconds, not minutes or hours,
as you would do
with a Map Reduce.
Dremel is available externally
by the Google Cloud Platform
as a BigQuery service.
Then there's Colossus.
Colossus is our second
generation file system,
and many of our data services
are built on top of Colossus.
Colossus has been made
available to Cloud Platform
users for many years now
as Google Cloud Storage.
Then there's innovation at
the infrastructure layer,
and we're going to talk
about Andromeda shortly.
So we have scale fast,
we have measure fast,
and we have the key
of innovate fast.
All of these things make to a
wonderful Google Cloud Platform
experience when you use it.
Not only do you get all of
these when you use Google Cloud
Platform, but you also
get fast connectivity
to the rest of Google
at no extra cost.
So if you want to consume Google
search results, YouTube videos,
maps data, finance data, you
can do so at no additional cost.
If you were using
another cloud provider,
you would probably have to
pay some additional charges
in order to get that
data into the cloud.
So I want to talk about how
some of the changes that we've
made to our infrastructure will
benefit Cloud Platform users,
and I'm going to do this
in the context of a feature
of our network infrastructure,
a network virtualization
that I called Andromeda.
And Andromeda provides all
of our virtualization needs.
So Andromeda is our
SDN-based, Software Defined
Networking-based network
backbone infrastructure.
It provides many
benefits to us in terms
of quality of service, fault
tolerance, and lower latency.
But it also provides all of
our virtualization services,
and that shows up in the form
of virtual networks for Google
Cloud Platform users.
Now, Andromeda was not built
as a Google Cloud Platform
product.
It was built
specifically to address
the needs of our own
internal infrastructure.
But because Google
Cloud Platform
runs on that same
infrastructure,
it gets the same
benefits when it
comes to high performance,
security, isolation,
and availability.
So we built Andromeda
really to address the ever
increasing demands of moving
traffic between storage
and compute, something
that traditional network
infrastructure really
wasn't able to keep up with.
So as you can imagine,
Andromeda is also
going to give us
better throughput.
So we have this graph here,
probably a bit of an eye chart
for some of you guys.
On the y-axis, we have
relative performance,
where higher is better.
And on the bottom, we
have compute engine
virtual machine instance times.
Standard is the standard
memory configuration,
and we have one, two,
four, and eight cores.
So these are bigger
machines as we go along
to the right of the x-axis.
The blue bars represent
the average performance,
the average
throughput, for what we
had before Andromeda, the
non-Andromeda average.
As you can see, this is
fairly static across all
those machines.
The red bar represents
Andromeda average,
the average we see
with Andromeda.
As you can see, with the
smaller instance, the one core
instance, we get almost double,
2x throughput performance
on that particular time.
When it comes to the
eight core instance,
we get roughly 4x improvement in
throughput on single stream TCP
connections.
So this makes these larger
instances perfectly suited
for network IO
intensive workloads,
such as maybe Hadoop, HPL,
any kind of application
that is extremely
sensitive to latency.
Just to mention
as well, Andromeda
is our network infrastructure.
It's available in
all of our zones
on Compute Engine is
all of our regions.
And on the subject
of latency-- it
was going to be the
subject of latency--
I'm going to hand
you over to Wes,
who's going to talk to
you about measuring fast.
WESTON HUTCHINS: Thanks, Mandy.
So I wanted to spend a little
bit of time talking around what
it means to measure
an application,
because you guys can
make all the performance
improvements in the
world, but if you
don't know how they're
impacting your application,
you may be doing something
bad under the covers
that you need to know about.
So normally, when I ask a web
developer, I say, hey John,
can you go tell
me the performance
of this particular web
page or application home
page loading screen
that's coming up?
The first number they almost
always come back with,
which is the easiest
thing to report,
is average response time.
A lot of monitoring
solutions report this to you.
But the thing I want to point
out is that this may look good.
200 milliseconds may
not seem that bad,
but that's only average.
How do I know if 10%,
20% of my customers
are seeing loading times of
greater than four seconds,
and then there's a lot of people
seeing really fast requests?
And average response
time is misleading.
The real point I wanted
to try to make here
is that anytime you
report an average,
it works well when
you have a model that
follows a normal
distribution curve.
When you see things where
it's like a few requests that
are very fast, most of them
in the middle, and then a few
tailing off at the
end, but the problem
is that most applications
don't behave like this.
In fact, this is actually a more
typical agency analysis curve
that you would see as
part of your web app
or mobile application.
And the reason is this
behaves a little bit more
like a step function, and it
actually makes a lot more sense
when you think about how an
app is architected and built.
At the very beginning
of the curve,
you see most of the requests.
This is a good thing, and this
is because most modern web
applications and apps
have some form of caching.
So users go and hit
your web server,
the cache serves the request,
gets the data locally,
and is able to send it back to
the customer really quickly.
But then what happens when
you have a cache miss?
Well, that's when things
take a little bit longer.
And so if most of the users are
hitting the cache, only a few
of them are missing
it, and this is
where you start to see
the decrease in the number
of people that experience
longer latency.
So as I said, it behaves
a little bit more
like a step function.
Finally, at the end,
you start seeing things
that we call the long tail.
This is where you need to
start really paying attention
to some of the stuff
that's going on.
This is the problematic
areas that you may see,
specifically this guy.
If this bump right
here starts to spike,
it's usually indicative
of a problem.
It could be your servers
are overloaded with traffic
and they're starting to fail.
It could be a third party
API that's timing out.
It really could just
be a programming bug.
We see a lot of examples where
some user comments end up
scaling out and causing
really slow response
times for a number of users.
Oftentimes, it could be a
variety of these things,
but you really want to start
paying attention to the tailer.
Googler Jeff Dean
says this best.
He goes, "Even if your
application appears
to be performing fast,
always be aware of the end
to end spectrum.
Don't just look at average.
Don't even look at
50th percentile.
Make sure that your long latency
tails are performing well."
So if averages aren't the
answer, what is the answer?
Typically, when we
talk about performance,
I love it when people
tell me percentiles
rather than averages.
And to give a really
quick, simple example,
imagine my application got
10 requests that were served.
Notice that the average of
this is 102 milliseconds,
but it actually
doesn't say anything
about how many users are
seeing average response
times of 102 milliseconds.
And if I go and take the
50th percentile of this,
I can then say, oh,
half of my customers
are experiencing latency
50 milliseconds or greater.
And this gives me
much more confidence
in the range of users that are
seeing good and bad performance
on my application.
So quiz time.
If I was to show you guys
a quick little graph of two
applications that have a latency
curve that looks like this,
which do you think is better?
Here two, here one, here
a little bit of both.
You're probably
sitting there saying,
you just told us that averages
aren't the right thing,
so of course, the answer is
it depends, and that's true.
In this particular example,
this is actually real world data
that we took from two apps
that we were running internally
at Google.
And we found that even
though the average of app two
was a little slower, the 95th
percentile was further in.
So we got really reliable,
predictable, consistent
performance, and it was under
that four second magic time.
App one had some
attrition rate from people
that didn't want to wait
for these long requests.
So really, the whole
point of this slide
is to start thinking about
the range of performance
across your
application, and also
realize that good
performance engineers to try
to bring forward the bars.
They try to move these
bars a little bit left
in terms of the
percentile graphs.
But any change that you make
can have an adverse affect
on the other percentiles,
so always keep that in mind.
You might make something better
for the 50th percentile which
will impact the 95th percentile.
And those are just
performance trade offs
that you're going to
have to figure out
what the right solution
is for your application.
So I'm going to come over
here and give you guys
a quick little demo.
You saw some of this
in the keynote today,
and I just wanted to show you
in a little bit more depth what
was going on.
We recently announced a
product called Cloud Trace,
and I want to show
you how that works.
This is a tool designed to help
you debug long latency tail
apps.
So I've loaded up
the Walk Share app,
and let me exit out
of the comment here.
It's a beautiful app that
says, this is where I walk.
Look how peaceful that looks.
Thank you, Mandy.
And it allows you to go
and comment and figure out,
OK, this is a nice walk
or it's not a nice walk,
or I've done better than that.
So I'm just going to go ahead
and add a test comment in here.
When I hit Post, this is
exhibiting some pretty long
characteristics.
There was a delay there.
It wasn't immediate.
And I noticed when
I was using this
that the more times I
had comments on the page,
the more it was lagging.
And so Cloud Trace is a tool
designed to help you figure out
what's going on there.
Under the Monitoring
tab, you can
go into the Developers
console and click on Traces,
and this is a tool that allows
you to see the requests that
are coming into your
application in real time.
So if I was to go
and filter to say,
let's take a look at
things in the last hour,
and I can even do some searches.
And then I'll sort
by latency to see
the slowest latency request.
This was actually
the recent request
that I made in an
earlier session.
I'll go ahead and pull
it up because the graph
should look similar.
But for every single
one of these comments,
the Cloud Trace tool
tells me how long
this particular
request took and then
gives me a list of the RPCs,
or Remote Procedure Calls,
that were made
during this request.
So it's really easy
for me to pull out
and say, well, I can
obviously see the problem.
I'm doing a bunch of
synchronous data store calls
in a loop, which is causing
it to basically block
on the number of
comments that I have.
In fact, if I even go and click
on some of these other tabs,
I can see that the
majority of my calls
are all in this data
store.get method.
And the fix for this
is pretty simple.
I ended up pulling
up some code here.
I'm not going to make the fix,
but what I wanted to call out
was I noticed that everything
that I was doing here
in data store was via
synchronous method.
We actually offer Async
counterparts to most of these.
So I fixed the
version of the app.
I ended up pushing that out
to production using the Async
APIs, and when I got was
a very different picture.
You can notice that most
of my data store calls
are now parallelized.
I'm doing some puts in
addition to some gets here.
This greatly sped
up the overall end
to end performance
of my application.
And a few more notes
on Cloud Trace.
Right now, this is a product
that's in limited preview.
We're going to support it
for App Engine right out
of the box.
Zero configuration.
You turn this on, you get these
traces for you automatically.
And as we start to roll
out the life cycle of this,
we really want to
extend this across
not just App Engine but
Compute Engine as well,
and give you guys detail
analysis on what these RPC
calls are doing, what code
line was calling them,
and really take a deep look
into what your service is doing
for every single request
that's coming in.
Now, before I hand
it back to Mandy,
I wanted to impart with you guys
a few little tips and tricks
for how to manage
long tail latency.
Tip number one.
Before you do anything, look
to reduce the number of RPCs
before optimizing
your algorithms.
So many times, I've
talked to people
where the first thing
they want to do is go
and hunt through
your code, through
every single in
squared algorithm,
and try to clean that
up into some n log
n or even fancier set of code.
And that's usually
not what speeds up
your application the most.
The number of RPC calls
every single request
makes is usually the
number one contributor
to slow performance.
And for this particular example,
this is a really common thing
I see where people are making a
bunch of Memcache or data store
calls, and they don't
realize that you can actually
batch these together.
Data store provides
really nice mechanisms
for retrieving data
via batch operation
where you're able to pass
in a set of keys as opposed
to each one individually.
Tip number two.
Cache read only third
party API calls.
The thing to remember is that if
you're making a bunch of calls
off to Facebook, Twitter,
Google Maps, whatever, they have
the same performance
characteristics
that your application
has as well.
So realize that for every 100
calls you make, 99% of them
are going to be very fast,
but there is a chance
that a few of them are
going to turn very slowly.
They could either time
out or they could just
take a long time to
return to you because they
have the same latency
curves just like you do.
Even worse, if you start to
load a page that chains a bunch
of these together, say, like
an account details page that
wants to show name, address,
billing information from all
these different services,
you're increasing the percentage
chance that one
of these services
is going to return slow.
And if your page
happens to block
on showing that
information, well, then you
end up in a little
bit of a problem.
So the tip here, when you can,
if you have some data that
is not likely to change
very often, is read only,
cache that locally.
Name and address are
really good examples
where you don't
necessarily need to make
API calls for all of that stuff.
Store it locally, make
the retrieval faster,
and try to reduce the number
of external dependencies
your application has.
And then the last one.
This is sort of a
no brainer but I
like to remind people
because not everyone realizes
that we have
asynchronous methods
for almost every single
one of our outgoing calls
in App Engine.
The synchronous methods
have an Async counterpart.
So really, learn
the documentation.
Be aggressive about
using the Async.
Put in a pretty
aggressive deadline limit.
You can actually
specify how long
to wait before a particular
RPC call is returned.
You can be a lot more aggressive
in sending out a few of those
just in case one of them
happens to return slowly.
And with that, Mandy is
going to talk to you guys
about, once you have everything
up and running, scaling
out fast so that
your application can
handle a lot of load.
MANDY WAITE: Thanks, Wes.
So what do you do when you
have to scale for a one
off global event involving one
of the biggest social media
entities on the planet?
How many of you have
heard of One Direction?
There wasn't many hands up.
I think most of you are liars.
You've all heard
of One Direction.
You just won't admit it.
Back in October of last
year, we received a request
from our marketing team
to assess an agency
with the development of a second
screen application for what
was known as One Direction Day.
And One Direction Day was a
seven hour continuous YouTube
live stream by the boy
band One Direction.
And we were told in October.
The event was on the
23rd of November.
It wasn't a huge amount
of time to get this done.
Also, scale was a
particular concern
because based on previous
live streams that they
had done with the
band, they estimated
a potential concurrent usage
of 650,000 concurrent users.
So because of the two factors,
the short amount of time
involved, and also because
of the scale involved,
the agency chose to
use Google App Engine.
This is what they
built, very simply.
The user would connect to
the App Engine application
and would be asked to log
in using Google+ sign in.
Once they'd logged
in, they would
be presented with questions.
New questions would be
available every 10 minutes,
six questions every hour,
42 questions in total,
and there's absolutely
no significance
in that number, 42.
So they were presented with
questions every 10 minutes
and they would
answer the question.
The client side code
would return the answer
to an endpoint, run it
in the same application.
An endpoint was
designed to handle
all of our data services.
And that data about any correct
answers, only correct answers,
were stored into mem cache,
along with any demographic
information that we have
that the user had allowed us
to actually gain from
the Google+ sign in.
Now, we stored it into
Memcache, but because this
was a one off event,
we didn't actually
store it through to
our back end store.
This wasn't a write
through cache.
This was just stored into cache.
Now, App Engine has a
shared mem cache service.
The service isn't
completely free.
They're shared across
all applications
running on App Engine.
Obviously, that would make
it a little bit volatile,
so we have this feature
as well in App Engine
called Dedicated Memcache, which
is what we used for this event.
We reserved about 20
gigabytes of space
in Memcache specifically
for our application.
So all of the data was
stored into Memcache,
and there was another
endpoint that's
not shown on the
diagram that was used
by the organizers of the
event to query that data that
was stored in Memcache.
And that allowed them to come
up with interesting statistics,
such as 95% of people in
the age range 20 to 30
in Brazil answered the
last question correctly.
They could then put
that data on the tickers
at the bottom of the live
stream and broadcast it live.
After the 42 questions
had been delivered,
we would drain the data.
After the event is
finished, the data
would be drained out Of
memcache into Cloud SQL, which
is our MySQL in
the cloud offering.
That's the application.
That's how complicated it
was, or not complicated.
So obviously, scale
was a big concern,
and we, in partnership
with the agency,
did lots of load testing
before the event.
After 10,000 queries
per second-- and queries
per second that we use
internally in Google
generally equates to
requests per second.
And that was great,
10k queries per second.
The URL of the application
was leaked before the event,
so we were able to see a
steady ramp up in traffic.
It was leaked
through social media,
so that ramp up was
relatively exponential,
but it did allow us to
test some assumptions,
and also to fix a couple of
issues that we saw with our API
quota around Google+.
We didn't leak the
URL, but if I was ever
going to do this again,
I would definitely
leak the URL myself just to make
that happen, but it was great.
Then we settled into this
steady traffic pattern
where we saw every five
minutes a peak of about 600,
a peak of about 700
queries per second.
That's what this
graph shows here.
Now, we had to try and avoid
the issue where potentially,
650,000 users would all answer
a question simultaneously.
So the delivery of the
questions or the availability
of questions was staggered
over a period of time.
That's why we have
two spikes and why
the spikes are reasonably broad.
So that went on for about four
hours, and about four hours
into the event, the
organizers of the live stream
decided to announce the
application live on the event.
And that gave us
this spike here,
a slightly different
x-axis here.
We saw a spike of 9,000 QPS.
And later on, we saw a spike of
around 5,000 or 6,000 as well.
So that was fine.
We'd tested up to 10,000
queries per second.
We had capacity to go
way beyond that as well.
So that was fine.
We had no problems
with that at all.
We had no problems with
this because App Engine just
scales inherently.
There's not a huge
amount a developer has
to do to actually
scale on App Engine.
Obviously, with an
event of this size where
we have to scale massively
and rapidly, there
are certain things we have
to do within the application
to make sure it doesn't
bottleneck or anything
like that.
But generally, if you're
building on App Engine,
you'll just scale.
The instances, it's very
small micro virtual machines,
are spun up very quickly,
torn down very quickly.
So you always have what
you need when you need it
but you only pay
for what you use.
But how do you scale Compute
Engine virtual machines?
So Compute Engine is
our infrastructure
as a service offering
where App Engine was
our platform as a
service offering,
and we're trying to blur the
lines between infrastructure
and platform.
So how would you go about
scaling Compute engine
virtual machines?
So you do it this way.
This is something
that we announced back
in March of this year.
We announced Deployment
Manager replica pools,
another thing called
resource views,
which we're not going to
talk about too much today.
They're a little bit obscure.
But basically, we like doing
things in Google declaratively.
We like creating templates or
config files and building stuff
from those templates
and config files.
This is an example template.
It's not really there
for you to read,
but this is an
example of a template.
That will be fed into a
service called Replica Pool,
and Replica Pool would
do all of the work
in converting that translate
into a deployment, which
would look something like that.
So this is a group
of virtual machines.
These are what Chris
[INAUDIBLE] would
call a fleet of homogeneous
virtual machines,
and they're all the same.
They're all identical.
They're all built
from this template.
There's no snowflake
service here.
And we have a load
balancer as well
configured to
distribute the load
across the pool of
virtual machines
with a single endpoint, a single
IP address you can connect to.
So for all intents
and purposes, they
look like one virtual
machine, but there's many.
Replica Pool also offers a
monitoring service as well.
So it can monitor the health
of these virtual machines,
and if they break, they can
bring them back up again.
This is all done from an agent
running on the virtual machine.
So that's Replica Pool.
This is a static resource.
We can scale it manually.
We can add replicas.
We can remove replicas and
size the pool manually.
But how would we manage auto
scale in this situation?
So now we're going to talk about
something called autoscaler.
Autoscaler is already available
as part of Deployment Manager.
Ultimately, it will be made
available as a separate API.
But autoscaler allows
you to create a config
within your template that
sets up auto scale parameters.
At the moment, the only
thing we can auto scale on--
and this will change-- is
average CPU utilization
across the entire pool.
And that's where
you'll see there
where it says Target
Utilization 0.5.
That's effectively
50% CPU utilization
averaged across the entire pool.
Whenever we go above 50%
utilization on average,
we'll spin up new instances.
Whenever we go below 50%, if
we have too many instances,
we'll turn them down.
That's how auto scale works.
And now, we're going to
give you a demo of that
actually working.
This is the kind of demo
you can spend 30 minutes on.
I'm going to try
and do it in three.
Can everybody read that?
Can everybody read it?
Yeah?
No no's?
OK, good.
I should have asked if
anybody couldn't read it.
So back to my
slides just briefly,
I just wanted to set that up.
I'm going to go
through the left hand
side of what this
demo looks like,
and then I'll go through
the right hand side
once I've kicked it off.
It takes a little
bit of time to run.
So we're going to be making
use of Google Cloud Storage.
Google Cloud Storage
is an object store.
It's a bucket-based store
for unstructured data.
It has a lot of really
nifty-- sorry, that's
a British term-- a lot
of really cool features
that you can make use of.
One of them, the one we're
going to make use of,
is called Object Notifications.
So we have these buckets.
We have an input bucket
and an output bucket.
So what we're going to do here
is solve a relatively complex
problem where a user has a
large number of images coming
from some source that she wants
to convert into thumbnails,
and she wants to do
this very quickly.
We don't know why she wants
to do it very quickly,
but she needs to
do it very quickly.
That's the problem we're
going to solve here.
So we have an
input bucket, which
will receive incoming
images, and an output bucket,
which will receive thumbnails.
So having said that, I'm going
to kick the actual copying
over of images off
now while I talk.
So Cloud Storage has
this tool called GS Util,
and it allows us to copy files
from one bucket to another.
So in this case, I
have a bucket that's
pre-configured with
exactly 1,111 images, which
I'm going to copy over from
that bucket to another bucket.
So the first thing we
need to do here, though,
is look at what we
have to begin with.
So if I go to the developer's
console, which we showed you
earlier, this is my replica
pool which I created before.
I've actually set
this replica pool up
with a load balancer
with one virtual machine,
and this is the virtual
machine, I/O 14 Demo Y598.
That's what we have.
You can see from the
spikes in the graph
that I have been practicing
this demo many, many times
over the last few days,
which is quite fun.
And it's always worked,
so hopefully today, it's
going to work as well.
So what else do we have?
We have Cloud Storage.
If I look at Cloud Storage,
we have three buckets.
We have our Images bucket, which
is where the input images are
going to come into, and we
have the Thumbnails bucket,
which is where the thumbnails
will be written to.
Then we have the
Payload bucket, and this
is where all of the images are.
This could be any source.
This could be some source of
images, a stream of images,
a batch of images,
but we're basically
going to copy them over
from one bucket to another.
So GS Util allows us to do that.
It allows us to copy from
one bucket to another.
So we're going to copy from
Autoscale-IO-Payload all
of the files into
Autoscale-IO-Images.
And we're going to
do this in parallel.
We're not going to pull
the files down and then
push them back up.
This is going to copy them
between the cloud storage
buckets directly, internal
Google infrastructure,
and we're going to
do it in parallel.
Because for some reason
this always seems to fail,
I'm going to do this first.
Ulimit minus n 10,000.
That allows me to have
10,000 file handles.
And for some reason, that
seem to reset itself every now
and again, and I
have no idea why.
Now we kick off
the copy, and that
will happen in the background
while I continue talking.
Is it more interesting
to watch this
or to listen to me talking?
I'm not sure.
So going back to the
slides, what we have here is
object notifications.
Object notifications are
really called whenever anything
is added to the bucket
or anything is updated
within the bucket, any object,
a notification will be fired,
and that notification will
be in the form of a URL which
is being called by
the notification.
So with every image
we add to the bucket,
we're going to have
one of these calls
specifically for
that image to a URL,
which we've registered
ahead of time.
And that URL could be a load
balanced pool of replicas,
a load balanced of
virtual machines.
But that gives us no
control over the way
in which data flows
into the system.
So we're going to use
something in App Engine.
We're going to use an
App Engine application
and something
called Task Queues.
How many of you have
heard of Task Queues?
Task Queues are one of the
best features of App Engine.
They allow us to actually
do work outside of the user
request.
So the request deadline for
a user request is 60 seconds.
Often, you want to do
work outside of that,
so you'll use a Task Queue
What you do is you create a
task, you put it onto a queue,
and then you have something
in App Engine consuming
those tasks from the queue at
a rate of, by default, five
every second.
The applications consuming those
tasks will process the request
and then create another HTTP
request to our pool of load
balanced virtual machines.
And this will be distributed
across our virtual machines,
hopefully in a round robin
style, across all of them.
We only have one to begin
with, so there's not
much to distribute.
But hopefully, we'll have more
before the end of the demo.
Then we have a process running
on the virtual machines that
will process the
images with Image Magic
and create a thumbnail.
So we go back to the Developer's
Console, look at that.
First thing we want to look
at is the Thumbnails bucket.
And hopefully when
I click on this,
we'll see a whole
bunch of thumbnails
which weren't there before.
So these are the thumbnails.
The thumbnails are
a picture of me
because I'm an egotist
or something like that.
So we're getting thumbnails.
That's good.
We want to get thumbnails.
What about these virtual
machines, though?
How many do we have?
We have two currently.
So we've doubled the
size of our pool.
We've added another virtual
machine to do processing.
So this basically is set up to
a threshold of 0.3, which 30%.
So we're looking for
30% CPU utilization.
The application running
on the virtual machines
is a Go application and
is using Go routines,
so it can do the request
processing in parallel.
Normally, we get four
virtual machines.
Today, we've only got two.
It really depends on how quickly
we can pull that data down,
suck it down from one
bucket to another.
So let's see what happens
and see if we get any more.
So now we've got four
virtual machines.
So now, what we're going to
do is go back to the slides
and look at one I created
earlier, in real just Julia
Child style, as
Julia would tell me.
And we have this
graph, which shows
you CPU utilization,
the blue bar,
against number of
virtual machines.
And obviously, this
wasn't for this one.
This was a run I
did on Saturday.
And you can see that as
we hit 30% threshold,
we spin up a new
virtual machine.
We spin up more
virtual machines.
The CPU utilizations come down.
At some point, we say, we have
too many virtual machines,
so we removed them.
Obviously, you don't want that
to keep happening bang, bang,
bang, bang, bang,
bang, so you have
this cool down period
where you can say,
there has to be a minimum of
this time between Auto Scale
activations, and
that's what happens.
That's the demo.
We'll come back to it
later if we have time.
So I just wanted to
share a couple of tips
with you, as Wes did,
with measuring fast,
a few tips on scaling fast.
The first one is always to use
Google App Engine as the entry
point for your web applications
and as the API service
for your mobile and
gaming back ends.
As we've seen with example
of One Direction Day,
App Engine scales extremely
well and extremely quickly,
and there's very, very
little work on your part
that you have to do.
Now, some applications are
best suited for App Engine,
and in that case, you can
build a modular application
where all of your front
side stuff is on App Engine
but virtual machines being
managed by App Engine
are running your back end code.
That's really easy
and simple to set up.
Also, make use of edge caching.
So we've seen that
with Andromeda, we
have much higher
throughput, particularly
on larger instances,
but throughput always
involves latency.
So any kind of movement of
stuff through the network
will involve latency.
The best thing to do is
cache your content as close
to the user as possible.
And you can make use of edge
caching, which is caching it
in our data centers,
or with ISPs,
because we have a global peering
relationship with many ISPs.
And you can do this with App
Engine using Static Content,
with Cloud Storage by
setting cache control
headers on any data you store.
And with App Engine,
again, you can do it
on dynamically generated
content by setting cache control
headers on the response stream.
And very quickly, because
we're running out of time,
I'm going to run through
these very quick.
For network I/O
intensive workloads,
make use of those big, virtual
machines for more network
throughput.
For scaling, App
Engine can sometimes
do with some help
for scaling, and you
can use idle instances
on App Engine
to make it scale that
little bit better.
Idle Instances effectively
answer requests
when there's no instance
available to actually answer
that request immediately.
They're [INAUDIBLE] as a
backup to answer requests.
And the final one
is to take advantage
of features such as
Page Speed and Memcache.
Page Speed effectively is an
App Engine application or App
Engine service that's
free to anybody
who has a paid
application, a set billing
app on your application, and
it will optimize your HTTP
request, it will
compress and cache data,
and it provides services such
as in lining and critical path
rendering.
Memcache.
You guys all know
how to use Memcache,
but you can also take advantage
of dedicated Memcache,
as we did with
One Direction Day.
So we've seen that Google is
built on a culture of fast,
and that we're constantly
driving innovation
within our infrastructure in
order to maintain and improve
performance across all
of our APIs and services.
We've also seen the Google
Cloud Platform benefits
from this innovation through
network stuff like Andromeda.
We've also seen that long
tail latency is an issue
and it can be addressed
with the ability
to measure fast,
as Wes showed you.
We looked at tools such
as Cloud Trace that
allow you to actually gain
rapid insight into issues
like [INAUDIBLE] running in
applications in the cloud.
And finally, fast matters.
We come back to the message
that Wes had initially.
Fast matters.
Fast will always matter,
and Google Cloud Platform
can help you build applications
that run fast in the cloud.
So what are you going to build?
With that, we're
going to sign off.
We've only got a couple
of minutes for questions.
The call to action, go to
the Cloud Platform blog
and find out about features
that Wes talked about
and that I talked about.
Preview features such
as Deployment Manager
and Replica Pools.
You can sign up there.
The next session is
in Room Seven, Zero
to Hero with Google Cloud
Platform with Chris Ramsdale.
You can provide feedback
via the QR code.
There's one up
there on the board.
And you probably haven't
received anything about this
yet, but you can get $500 in
credits for the Google Cloud
Platform.
Go to g.co/CloudStarterPack and
enter the promo code GoogleIO.
And there's also a road show
in the US happening very soon,
and you can go to
googlecloudroadshow.com
to sign up for that.
WESTON HUTCHINS: Great.
If you guys have any
questions, Mandy and I
are going to be sitting outside
in the cloud booth over there,
so come find us.
Thank you very much.